Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. 70,000 people are here and Bob Dylan is the reason for it. Inspired by the true story. If anyone is going to hold your attention on the stage, you have to kind of be a freak. Are you a freak? Hope so.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。7万名听众齐聚于此，而这一切都要归功于鲍勃·迪伦。本片改编自真实故事。如果你想在舞台上吸引所有人的目光，你必须有点怪异的特质。你是个怪咖吗？希望你是。
And starring Timothee Chalamet as Bob Dylan, he defied everyone. Turn it down! Play loud! To change everything. Make some noise, BD. Timothee Chalamet, Edward Norton, Elle Fanny, Monica Barberow,
蒂莫西·柴勒梅德饰演鲍勃·迪伦，他挑战了所有人。把声音调小点！放大声点！去改变一切。制造点噪音吧，BD。蒂莫西·柴勒梅德、爱德华·诺顿、艾丽·范宁、莫妮卡·巴巴罗，
a complete unknown. Only theaters Christmas day. The holidays are almost here, but Amazon still has last minute deals. Like makeup for the beauty lover, electronics for the tech pro, and home goods for the host who was too busy hosting to shop. Shop last minute deals at Amazon now.
一个完全未知的人。圣诞节仅在各大影院上映。节日即将来临，但亚马逊仍有最后一刻的特惠。比如送给美妆爱好者的美妆产品、给科技达人的电子产品，还有送给忙于招待客人而没时间购物的主人的家居用品。现在就在亚马逊选购最后一刻的特惠商品吧。
You know what's great about ambition? You can't see it. Some things look ambitious, but looks can be deceiving. For example, a runner could be training for a marathon, or they could be late for the bus. You never know. Ambition is on the inside. So that goal to be the ultimate soccer parent?
你知道雄心最棒的地方是什么吗？它是看不见的。有些事情看起来雄心勃勃，但外表往往具有欺骗性。例如，一个跑步者可能在为马拉松进行训练，也可能只是赶公交迟到了。你永远猜不到。雄心是内在的。那么，成为终极足球父母的目标呢？
Keep chasing it. Drive your ambition. Mitsubishi Motors. The Merovingian dynasty, from which the Franks were accustomed to choose their kings, is thought to have lasted down to King Chilperic III, who was deposed on the order of Stephen II, the Pope of Rome. His hair was cut short and he was shut up in a monastery. Though this dynasty may seem to have come to an end only with Chilperic III, it had really lost all power years before and it no longer possessed anything at all of importance beyond the empty title of King.
继续追逐它吧。驱动你的雄心。三菱汽车。法兰克人习惯于从墨洛温王朝选择他们的国王，这个王朝一直延续到希尔佩里克三世国王，他被罗马教皇斯蒂芬二世下令废黜。他的头发被剪短，并被关进了一座修道院。虽然这个王朝似乎只随着希尔佩里克三世的去世而终结，但实际上它在多年前就已经失去了所有的权力，除了空洞的国王头衔外，它再也没有任何重要价值了。
The wealth and the power of the kingdom were held tight in the hands of certain leading officials of the court, who were called the Mayors of the Palace, and on them supreme authority devolved. All that was left to the King was that content with his royal title, he should sit on the throne, with his hair long and his beard flowing, and act the part of a ruler. Whenever he needed to travel, he went in a cart which was drawn in rural manner by yoked oxen with a cowherd to drive them. In this fashion he would go to the palace and to the general Assembly of his people,
王国的财富和权力紧紧地掌握在宫廷中某些主要官员的手中，他们被称为宫相，最高权力便落在了他们身上。留给国王的全部权力就是，满足于他的皇家头衔，坐在王座上，留着长发和飘逸的胡须，扮演统治者的角色。每当他需要出行时，他就坐一辆由套着轭的牛以乡村方式拉着的四轮马车，由一个放牛人赶着它们。他就是这样前往宫殿和他的臣民的公民大会，
which was held each year to settle the affairs of the kingdom, and in this fashion he would return home again. That's the opening to the life of Charlemagne by Einhart, the Frankish scholar and courtier, and he wrote that just after Charlemagne's death and he's describing the greatest, the most famous of all Frankish kings, one of the titanic names in all European history. Lots of people, I think Tom, will have heard the name of Charlemagne. But to be completely honest, I think a lot of people have heard the name and have no real sense of who he was.
每年召开一次大会是为了处理王国的事务，然后他又以这种方式返回家园。这是法兰克学者兼朝臣艾因哈德所著的《查理曼传》的开篇，他是在查理曼死后不久写下这段话的，他描述的是所有法兰克国王中最伟大、最著名的一位，也是欧洲历史上如雷贯耳的名字之一。汤姆，我想很多人都听说过查理曼大帝的名字。但老实说，我认为很多人只是听过这个名字，却并不真正了解他是谁。
Was he French? Was he German? Well, obviously he was neither. Well, he's the father of both and yet was neither. Now, Einhart, let's just talk about Einhart for a second because he writes this very extraordinary biography of Charlemagne, doesn't he? Yeah, pretty unique, really. Yeah. And he was very proud of the fact that he had been so familiar personally with Charlemagne,
他是法国人吗？他是德国人吗？嗯，很显然，他两者都不是。嗯，他是两者的之父，然而却两者都不是。现在，艾因哈德，让我们先来谈谈艾因哈德，因为他写了这本非常非凡的查理曼传记，不是吗？是的，确实相当独特。是的。而且他非常自豪于自己曾与查理曼有过如此亲密的个人交往，
wasn't he? Yeah. He was also a very short man, Dominic. So like Benjamin Lay. Oh, yes. We love a short man on the rest of history. We do, yes. Well, so the thing that's unusual about this is that it's a biography in a kind of Roman style. It echoes Suetonius, the biographer of the Caesars, and that's not a coincidence because Einhardt as a young boy had been sent by his parents to a monastery, not to become a monk,
对吧？是的。多米尼克，他也是个身材非常矮小的人。就像本杰明·莱一样。哦，是的。我们“历史的余烬”节目最喜欢矮个子男人了。确实是的。好吧，关于这件事不寻常的地方在于，这是一部带有罗马风格的传记。它呼应了凯撒传记作家苏埃托尼乌斯的作品，这并非巧合，因为艾因哈德在年轻时曾被父母送往一座修道院，不是为了去当修士，
but kind of rather like being sent to a boarding school or something like that, at a place called Fulda on the east bank of the Rhine. And this monastery had a complete collection of Suetonius' Lives of the Caesars. And this included a biography of the greatest of all the Roman emperors, Augustus. And Ironheart read it. And so when he came to write his biography of Charlemagne, he modelled it on Suetonius' life of Augustus. And this is very deliberate because the extraordinary thing about Charlemagne, who is this descendant of barbarian warlords, is that on Christmas AD 800. He had been crowned as a Caesar, as Augustus in Rome by the Pope himself. And you said how Charlemagne is a titanic figure in the history of Europe, simultaneously a kind of dominant but also shadowy, I think. And this is the key moment in his reign. And
而是有点像被送到寄宿学校之类的地方，那是在莱茵河东岸一个叫富尔达的地方。这个修道院里藏有一整套苏埃托尼乌斯的《罗马凯撒传》。其中就包括最伟大的罗马皇帝奥古斯都的传记。艾因哈德读了这本书。因此，当他着手撰写查理曼大帝的传记时，他便以苏埃托尼乌斯的奥古斯都传记为蓝本。这是非常刻意的，因为查理曼大帝这位蛮族军阀的后代，其非凡之处在于，在公元800年的圣诞节，他在罗马被教皇亲自加冕为凯撒、奥古斯都。正如你所说，查理曼是欧洲历史上的一位巨擘，我认为他同时既是一个占统治地位的人物，又带有一种神秘的色彩。这是他统治时期的关键时刻。而
again, it's a moment that is simultaneously epical yet also hard to get a sense of exactly why it matters. The kind of the meaning seems to slip as you try to grasp it. Because even the empire that he ends up in a vertical was ruling, the Holy Roman Empire, a lot of people have find it very hard to pin down neither Holy nor Roman nor an empire famously was said about. Actually, I think it was Holy, I think it was Roman and I think it was an empire for reasons that were come to, but you're right. So this is looking back to the age of the Roman Empire, to the age of Augustus, but
同样，这也是一个既具有划时代意义，却又很难确切理解其重要性所在的时刻。当你试图抓住它时，那种意义似乎就溜走了。因为即使是他最终统治的那个帝国——神圣罗马帝国，许多人也发现很难对其实际定义进行界定：既不神圣，也非罗马，更不是帝国，这是句名言。其实，我认为它是神圣的，我认为它是罗马的，而且我认为它是一个帝国，原因我们稍后会讲到，但你说得对。所以这既是在回顾罗马帝国的时代、奥古斯都的时代，但
it's also looking forward to the medieval empire and the empire that will endure right the way up to the time of Napoleon, who is the guy who abolishes it. So you could say, I mean, I said that, you know, the story of the Franks, it's a kind of hinge moment in European history. This perhaps is the key hinge moment. This is the kind of the middle point in the emergence of Europe from antiquity, from the world of ancient Rome into what will become the Europe of the high middle ages. And it's kind of the ultimate promotion, a Frankish warlord becoming a Caesar.
它也是在展望中世纪的帝国，以及这个将一直持续到拿破仑时代的帝国，拿破仑正是废除它的人。所以你可以说，正如我所说，法兰克人的故事是欧洲历史上的一个关键转折点。这或许就是最核心的转折点。这是欧洲从古代、从古罗马世界向将成为中世纪高地欧洲的过渡时期的中点。而这可以说是终极的晋升，一个法兰克军阀成为了一名凯撒。
And so the question is, how had this absolutely jaw-dropping event happened? And this is the story that we will be telling. We'll be starting on it today and completing it in the next two episodes. And we'll be finishing this story, of of course on Christmas Day. So the anniversary of Charlemagne's coronation. Okay, let's get going and let's get a sense of the context. In the last three episodes, we talked about the rise of the Franks, the warlords of the West and we ended with the Battle of Tours. And people who listened to the first episode will remember that Charlemagne
所以问题是，这个绝对让人惊掉下巴的事件是如何发生的？这就是我们要讲述的故事。我们今天将开始讲述，并在接下来的两集中完成它。当然，我们将在圣诞节那天结束这个故事。也就是查理曼加冕的周年纪念日。好了，让我们开始吧，让我们来了解一下背景。在过去的三集里，我们讨论了法兰克人的崛起、西方军阀的兴起，我们以图尔战役结束。听过第一集的听众会记得，查理曼
is not in fact the first Frankish warlord to have the title of Augustus. They all remember that three centuries earlier, another Frankish warlord, that is to say Clovis, had been hailed as Augustus, but not in Rome, in Tor in the shrine of St. Martin. He wasn't crowned by the Pope, he was crowned by himself like Napoleon. Yeah. And that reflects the fact that Clovis is very much a kind of self-made man. He has been given the title of a consul by the emperor in Constantinople. But the idea that he's an Augustus, I mean, this is a self-promotion,
实际上并不是第一个获得奥古斯都称号的法兰克军阀。大家都会记得，三个世纪前，另一个法兰克军阀，也就是克洛维，曾被欢呼为奥古斯都，但不是在罗马，而是在图尔的圣马丁神殿。他不是由教皇加冕的，而是像拿破仑那样由自己加冕的。是的。这反映了一个事实，即克洛维在很大程度上是一个白手起家的人。他被君士坦丁堡的皇帝授予了执政官的称号。但关于他是一个奥古斯都的想法，我的意思是，这是一次自我宣传，
and it reflects the fact that he is casting himself simultaneously as the heir of Roman power in Gaul. You know, this is what he's laying claim to, but also that he is a kind of barbarian warlord. So he's not interested in ruling a global empire empire as Augustus had done, as Charlemagne will aspire to do. He's content with being King of the Franks, but I mean, that's still an absolutely massive deal. And to justify his authority, he's casting himself as the equivalent of a Roman governor, but also, you know, he's the descendant of a weird sea creature.
这反映出他一方面把自己塑造成高卢罗马权力的继承者。你知道，这就是他所宣称的，但同时他也认为自己是一个蛮族军阀。所以他并不像奥古斯都那样有兴趣统治一个全球帝国，不像查理曼以后所渴望的那样。他满足于做法兰克人的国王，但是，这仍然是一件非常重大的事情。为了证明他的权威，他把自己塑造成罗马总督的代名词，而且，你知道，他是一个奇异海洋生物的后代。
He's got his long hair. He's got all this kind of stuff. He's got his very tight pants over his enormous genitals, all this stuff that marks him out as being simultaneously Roman and Frankish. And that passage that you read, I mean, Einhard mentions some of the things that Clovis had worn and which the Merovician kins have inherited. The long hair, the beard, the carts. The long hair particularly. Yeah. So the reggae's croniti, the long-haired kings, this is what kind of defines them.
他留着长发。他有所有这些乱七八糟的东西。他那巨大的生殖器外面穿着非常紧身的裤子，所有这些特征都标志着他既是罗马人又是法兰克人。你读的那段文字，我的意思是，艾因哈德提到了克洛维穿过的一些衣服，以及墨洛温王室继承下来的东西。长发、胡须、四轮马车。尤其是长发。是的。因此，长发国王们，这正是定义他们的东西。
But the thing is that by the time of Ainhardt's writing, so he's doing that kind of what, maybe 820, 830, these attributes are cast as kind of grotesque, as rustic, as embarrassing. And it reflects a sense that the Merovingians themselves as the generations have passed, as their power kind of bleeds away, have become mere shadows of Clovis, the founder of their dynasty. They've become kind of phantasms. What French scholars have always called the do-nothing kings, kings who play no role in the functioning of the Frankish state. And the obvious question is why has this happened? How is it that the heirs of Clovis are just ciphers? And Einhard, in that passage you read, I mean again, he gives the answer. He says that they've been put in the
但问题是，到了艾因哈德写作的时代，也就是大概公元820、830年左右，这些特征被描绘成一种怪诞的、粗野的、令人尴尬的东西。这反映了一种感觉：随着代际更迭，随着他们的权力逐渐消逝，墨洛温王朝自身已经变成了他们的王朝奠基人克洛维的单纯影子。他们已经变成了某种幻影。法国学者们一直称他们为“什么都不做的国王”，即在法兰克国家的运作中不发挥任何作用的国王。显而易见的问题是，为什么会这样？为什么克洛维的继承人会沦为无足轻重的傀儡？而在你读的那段文字中，艾因哈德再次给出了答案。他说，他们被一群被称为宫相的官员掩盖了
shadow by officials known as mayors of the palace. And these are posts that by the beginning of the eighth century have become, like the kingship of the Merovingians themselves, a hereditary post. And in the previous episode, the episode we did on the Battle of Tor, we met one of those kind of domineering mayors of the palace, and that was Charles Charles, who in Einhard's time would come to be known as Martel the Hammer. So Charles Martel the Hammer. And, Charles Martel the Hammer. And he's the bloke who won the battle at all, of course. He absolutely is.
光芒。到了八世纪初，这些职位已经变得和墨洛温王朝的王权本身一样，是一个世袭的职位。在上一集，也就是我们关于图尔战役的那集中，我们遇到了其中一位盛气凌人的宫相，那就是查理，在艾因哈德的时代，他被称为“铁锤查理”。所以就是铁锤查理。而且，铁锤查理。他当然就是那个赢得图尔战役的人。他绝对是。
And this redounds greatly to his reputation. But the thing is that long before he wins that battle, he's already won, even though he named himself as the most formidable warrior, not just in the lands of the Franks, but in the whole of Christendom. He's used his expertise in war to fashion a really quite coherent empire. So he's the master of Austrasia, where his forebears came from, so that's the eastern Frankish kingdom stretching in beyond the Rhine into Germany. He's the master of Neustria, which is the Frankish kingdom that extends along the line
这极大地提升了他的声誉。但问题是，早在赢得那场战役之前，他已经赢得了胜利——尽管他确立了自己不仅是法兰克人土地上，而且是整个基督教世界中最令人生畏的战士的地位。他利用自己在战争中的专业知识，建立了一个相当连贯的帝国。所以他是奥斯特拉西亚的主人，他的祖先就来自那里，也就是横跨莱茵河进入德国的东方法兰克王国；他是纽斯特里亚的主人，这是沿着
of the channel. He has in the wake of the Battle of Tours, he's moved southwards to start trying to bring Provence and Aquitaine under his rule. So for Charles, the defeat of the invading Aemaiads, the invading Saracens, I mean this is brilliant, it's excellent for his reputation, but the thing he really cares about is fashioning a proper empire out of all the disparate parts of the kind of the Regnum Francorum, the Kingdom of the Franks. And Tor helps him, particularly with subordinating Aquitaine, because Odo, the Duke of Aquitaine, who had been Charles's rival, he had
海峡延伸的法兰克王国。在图尔战役之后，他向南进发，开始试图将普罗旺斯和阿基坦置于他的统治之下。因此，对查理来说，击败入侵的倭马亚人、入侵的萨拉森人，这真是太棒了，对他的声誉极好，但他真正关心的是从法兰克王国各种零散的部分中建立一个真正的帝国。图尔战役帮助了他，尤其是帮助他使阿基坦臣服，因为阿基坦公爵奥多曾是查理的对手，他
been smashed up by the invading Saracens. Odo had come to Charles to ask for help. Charles had agreed but Odo had had to submit to him and in 735 actually Odo retires to a monastery. Now his son and his grandson will continue the fight but basically they're on a losing wicket by this point. There's no way that they're going to ultimately be able to hold out against the might that Charles and his heirs can bring to bear on them. And this is also in the long run true of Muslims in the south of Gaul. So Charles targets them as well. So he advances southwards, he drives them out from the great fortresses of Arles, of Avignon. He annihilates a massive seaborne expedition of Umayyad forces outside Narbonne. There's descriptions of the Muslim fugitives trying desperately to swim back to their ships, being pursued by the victorious
被入侵的萨拉森人击溃了。奥多来到查理那里寻求帮助。查理同意了，但奥多不得不向他臣服，事实上，在735年，奥多退隐到了修道院。现在他的儿子和孙子将继续战斗，但基本上他们在此时已经处于劣势。他们最终绝无可能抵抗住查理及其继承人所能施加的强大力量。从长远来看，高卢南部的穆斯林也是如此。因此，查理也将他们作为目标。于是他向南挺进，将他们驱逐出阿尔勒和阿维尼翁的宏伟要塞；他在纳博讷城外全歼了一支庞大的倭马亚海上远征军。有记载称，穆斯林逃亡者拼命游回他们的船上，遭到胜利的法兰克人的追捕，在浅滩和泻湖中像金枪鱼一样被长矛刺中。如果你是个法兰克人，这真是妙极了。
Franks, being speared in the shallows and the lagoons like tuna. Fabulous stuff if you're a Frank. And by 741, which is when Charles Martel finally dies, his armies, so the Franks under his leadership, pretty much have the range of lands stretching from the Pyrenees all the way to the Danube, so a vast, vast expanse of territory. So the Frankish lords of southern Gaul and the Ameids, these are people who've been comprehensively hammered by Charles Martel, but they're not alone. So too have a very distinctive class in Frankish society and these are the bishops. And we talked about this in the first episode we did on the age of Clovis. The bishops, almost without exception, are the heirs of the kind of the old Gallo-Roman aristocracy, the kind of senatorial figures
到741年查理·马特最终去世时，他的军队——也就是在他领导下的法兰克人——几乎将势力范围从比利牛斯山一直延伸到多瑙河，这是一片极其辽阔的领土。因此，高卢南部的法兰克领主和倭马亚人，这些人都是被铁锤查理彻底痛击过的人，但他们并不孤单。法兰克社会中还有一个非常独特的阶层，那就是主教们。我们在关于克洛维时代的第一集里讨论过这一点。主教们几乎无一例外都是曾经富有的加洛罗马贵族、也就是罗马高卢富裕精英阶层的古老继承者。这些家族通过主教职位这一体制，通过让自己被当地城市选举为主教，依然保留着他们的权威。如果你想要找一个保留了消亡的罗马帝国传统的阶层，法兰克的主教们就是你的不二人选。所以他们知识渊博、学识广博，不仅受过古典诗歌的教育，也受过圣经及所有类似东西的教育。他们可能在宏大的国家舞台上扮演某种角色，但最终，他们真正的忠诚并不在于宏大的国家舞台，最终，他们的忠诚并不在于
who had been the wealthy elites of Roman Gaul. And these families still preserve their authority through the institution of the episcopate, through having themselves elected by their local cities as bishops. If you want an example of a class of people who preserve the traditions of the vanished Roman Empire, Frankish bishops are your guys. So they're very learned, they're very scholarly, they're kind of educated in classical poetry as well as in the Bible and all that kind of stuff. They may well play a kind of part on the great national stage, but ultimately their real loyalty isn't to the kind of part on the great national stage, but ultimately, their real loyalty isn't to the kind of the distant Frankish king or, you know, in the case
遥远的法兰克国王，或者（以查理·马特为例）遥远的法兰克宫相，而是效忠于他们在高卢舞台上所代表的那个地方城市、本地社区，其人民选举了他们。对于绝大多数法兰克人来说，正是主教们在广大基督徒与神圣维度之间起到了沟通和中介的作用。他们之所以能做到这一点，是因为他们几乎无一例外都是那些圣徒和主教的后代，而这些圣徒和主教的陵墓就座落在他们所在的主教座堂里。所以这是一个类似于家族的项目。而其结果就是，在高卢各地，无论你走到哪里，到处都有这些殉道者、圣人、
of Charles Martel, the distant Frankish mayor, but to the local city, the local community that they represent on the stage of Gaul and whose peoples have elected them. And for the vast majority of Franks, it's the bishops who kind of mediate between the mass of Christians and the dimension of the divine. And they're able to do this because they are almost invariably the descendants of saints and bishops whose tombs are in the cathedrals where they sit. So it's a kind of family project. And the effect of this is that all across Gaul, wherever you go, there are these tombs of martyrs, of holy
主教的陵墓。我的意思是圣马丁是最著名的一个，但绝不是唯一的一个。这使得法兰克人在看到他们的主教时，不仅能感受到他们与消亡的罗马帝国有着活生生的联系——我的意思是他们此时并不真正在乎这一点——但他们可以看着他们的主教，感受到他们是一个非常古老的基督教的古老代表。这使他们觉得高卢就像是一片圣地，一片基督教的圣地。例如，他们并不真正需要教皇的批准之类的东西。他们拥有圣马丁。
men, of bishops. I mean, St Martin is the most famous of these, but he's by no means the only one. And it enables the Franks, when they look at their bishops, to feel not just that they have living links with the, you know, the vanished realm of Rome. I mean, they don't really care about this by this point, but they can look at their bishops to feel not just that they have living links with the, you know, the vanished realm of Rome. I mean, they don't really care about this by this point, but they can look at their bishops and feel these are venerable representatives of a very, very ancient Christianity. And it enables them to feel that Gaul is like a kind of Holy Land, a Christian Holy Land. They don't really need, for instance, the sanction of the papacy or whatever. They've got St Martin.
他们拥有这一切。是的，本质上他们在精神上是自给自足的，自法兰克君主制初露端倪以来一直如此。但关于查理·马特，他一点也不喜欢这样。他大概不会容忍一个替代的权力基地吧？是的，基本上是这样。他不喜欢这些主教。他们太独立了。
They've got all that stuff. Yeah, essentially they're spiritually self-sufficient and this has been the case ever since the first emergence of the Frankish monarchy. But the thing about Charles Martel, he doesn't like this at all. He won't tolerate an alternative power base, presumably. Yeah, basically. He doesn't like these bishops. They're too independent.
他们太能够违背他的意愿了。因此，他想要做的是用他自己的亲信、他自己信任的盟友来取代他们。对于查理来说，他任命的主教是否懂得维吉尔之类的不重要，他不关心他们的教育水平，也不关心他们与即将担任主教的城市是否有地方联系，或者他们是否与陵墓位于其大教堂中的圣徒有家族联系。这类人正在被挤到一边，查理正把他的亲信安插到他们的位置上。实际上，我认为这是罗马高卢的最后消亡。
They're too able to defy his will. And so what he wants is to replace them with his own kinsmen, with his own trusted allies. And it doesn't matter to Charles if the bishops he appoints, you know, kind of no Virgil or whatever, he doesn't care about their educational standards or whether they have local links to the cities that they are going to serve as bishops for, or if they have family connections to the saints whose tombs lie in their cathedrals. So that class of person is being elbowed aside and Charles is putting in their place, you know, his own henchmen. And effectively, this is, I think, the final extinction of Roman Gaul.
这就是高卢变成法兰克尼亚（Francia）的地方。而法兰克尼亚这个词正是我们今天“法国”（France）这个名字的来源。所以你可以看到，在铁锤查理的统治下，高卢在这个时候正在变成法国。帕特里克·吉里（Patrick Geary）是研究这一进程的伟大历史学家之一，他的看法非常有趣。所以我把他的原话读给大家听。铁锤查理完成了在此之前的这一进程中没有任何其他世俗力量能够做到的事情。非常有趣，所以我把他的原话完整地读出来。世俗支持者。他最终成功地摧毁了法兰克主教长期以来赖以维持独立权力的宗教基础。此后，他们将成为强大的领主，有时在权力上与公爵、伯爵甚至国王相抗衡，但他们将再也不会拥有那种作为神圣事物垄断者的特殊权力。这种角色，连同在文化生活中的主导地位，将转交给修道院。
This is where Gaul, if you like, becomes Frankia. And Frankia is the word that will give us the name of France. So you can see Gaul becoming France at this point under the rule of Charles Martel and Patrick Geary, who's one of the great historians of this process. It's so interesting. So I'll read what he says in full. Charles Martel accomplished what no other secular power had been able to do in the previous of this process. It's so interesting so I'll read what he says in full. lay supporters. He finally succeeded in destroying the religious basis on which had long rested the independent power of the Frankish bishops. Henceforth they would be powerful lords at times rivaling in power dukes, counts and even kings, but they would never again command
所以这无疑是从古典时代晚期向中世纪早期过渡的一个关键时刻，对吧？罗马文化精神生活的一种残余被粉碎了，更多的权力集中到了现在自立为王的军阀手中。是这样吗？是的，我完全这么认为。而使这一进程的影响更加复杂的是在高卢南部，那里的罗马文明根基深厚得多，存在的时间也更长，城市文明在一定程度上得以存活下来，而这在北部高卢是没有的。
that particular power as monopolists of the sacred. This role, along with the lead in cultural life, would pass to monasteries. So this is surely a key moment in the transition from late antiquity to early medieval, right? That a vestige of kind of Roman cultural spiritual life has been smashed, more power has been concentrated in the hands of the warlords who are now making themselves kings. Is that right? Yeah, I think absolutely. And what compounds the impact of this process is that in the south of Gaul, where Roman civilisation had been much more deeply planted, it had been there for much longer, urban civilisation had kind of survived to a degree that it hadn't in northern Gaul.
那里的城市在过去的几十年里被彻底砸成了碎片，先是遭到阿拉伯入侵者的打击，然后是查理·马特向南入侵并试图收复这些城市。因此，这不仅意味着老派的罗马主教被扫地出门，还意味着维持这些主教的城市的独立性也遭到了巨大的毁灭。所以去过法国南部的人，如果你想到尼姆、阿尔勒或类似的地方，那里仍然有令人难以置信的宏大罗马遗迹。但这正是它们也开始真正瓦解的时刻，就像北方的罗马城市
The cities there have, over the previous decades, have been absolutely smashed to pieces, first by the Arab invaders and then by Charles Martel's invasion south and his attempt to reclaim these cities. So it's not just that the old Roman bishops have been swept aside. It's also that the independence of the cities that had maintained them has also been massively shattered. So people who've been to the south of France, if you think of Nîmes or Arles or whatever, there are still incredibly impressive Roman remains there. But this is the point where they are really starting to crumble away as well, as Roman
已经做过的那样。它们开始遭到侵蚀和拆解，在战争中支离破碎。正如你所说，我认为这确实是高卢古典时代晚期的终点。这就是某种意义上的中世纪开始的地方。我的意思是，这是古典时代晚期的终点。这就是某种意义上的中世纪开始的地方。我的意思是，这是一个起点。显然，主教们，也就是罗马老派、旧制度（Ancien Régime）的人，对此深恶痛绝。
cities, kind of in the north, had already done. They start to be cannibalised, they crumble away, they're shattered by wars. And as you say, I think this is really the kind of the end point of late antiquity in Gaul. This is where the kind of, if you want to say, the Middle Ages begin. I mean, this is the kind of the endpoint of late antiquity in Gaul. This is where the kind of, if you want to say the middle ages begin. I mean, this is the kind of the start point. And obviously the bishops, the kind of the Roman old school, the Ossian regime, they hate this.
我的意思是，他们感到无比愤慨。这里有一个极好的例子，那就是奥尔良的前主教，他叫欧卡里乌斯（Eucharius），这是一个罗马名字，这非常说明问题，因为到了八世纪这个时候，大多数罗马名字都在逐渐消失。它们正在被法兰克名字所取代。是的，人们都叫西奥德沃尔夫（Theodawolf）之类名字。没错，希尔德贝尔特（Childerbert）之类的。但在这种源自参议员等阶层的人中间，他们确实保留了自己的罗马名字。所以你可以从欧卡里乌斯这个名字看出他是一个非常显赫的人物，
I mean, they're so resentful. And there's a perfect example of this in the form of the erstwhile bishop of Orléans, who's a man called Eucharius and that's a Roman name and that's really telling because by this point in the 8th century most Roman names are fading away. They're being replaced by Frankish names. Yeah, people are all called Theodawolf or something. Exactly, Childerbert or whatever. But among this kind of class of, you know, descended from senators and so on, they do preserve their Roman name. So you can tell from Eucharius that he's kind of very grand figure, you know, with
其血统可以追溯到罗马的过去。不管怎样，图尔战役后查理出现在奥尔良，情绪高昂，意气风发，他击退了敌人，而欧卡里乌斯对他却又恼火、又闷闷不乐、又摆出势利眼的态度。铁锤查理直接对他说：“滚一边去，我再也不需要你了”，并用他自己的一个亲信取代了他。欧卡里乌斯对此愤怒至极，随后在铁锤查理死后，他报告说，他看到了一个梦境，梦中天使向他展示了一个幻象。这位天使带领欧卡里乌斯来到地狱，在那里他向欧卡里乌斯展示了查理·马特在肉体和灵魂上都被判处了永恒的惩罚。欧卡里乌斯醒来后对这个幻象感到兴奋不已，逢人便说这绝对是个天大的好消息。
lineage going back to the Roman past. Anyway, Charles turns up in Orléans after the Battle of Tours, very chipper, very full of himself, he's beaten the enemy off, and Eucharius is kind of grumpy and grouchy and snobbish towards him. Charles Martel just says piss off don't want you anymore replaces him with one of his own henchmen and Eukarius is furious about this and in due course when Charles Martel dies he reports he reports a vision that he's been shown in a dream by an angel and this angel leads Eucharist down into hell and there he shows him Charles Martel condemned in body and soul to eternal punishment. And Eucharist wakes up absolutely thrilled by this vision, tells everyone absolutely great news.
查理·马特在地狱里。他说：“如果你想要证据，我们去查理·马特的陵墓看看吧。让我们打开它，看看尸体还在不在，如果不在，那就证明尸体已经被带走并浸泡在烈火腾腾的地狱大锅里了。”于是，一行人聚集起来，他们来到查理的陵墓前，将其打开，我将引用随后关于发生的事情的记录。因此，他们来到了前面提到的埋葬查理尸体的修道院。他们打开了他的陵墓，突然间，多米尼克，一条龙钻了出来。整个陵墓内部都被熏黑了，
Charles Martel is in hell and he says, you know, if you want proof for this, let's go to Charles Martel's tomb. Let's open it up and see if the body's there because if it's not there, that will be evidence that the body has been taken away and dunked in the boiling vats of the inferno. So a party got together, they go to Charles' tomb, they open it up and I will quote from a subsequent record of what happens. Therefore, they went to the aforementioned monastery where Charles' body was buried. They opened his tomb and suddenly Dominic, a dragon emerged. And the whole interior of the tomb was found to be blackened
就像被火烧过一样。这真的发生了。嗯，就在本系列的开始以及我们在关于克洛维的那集中，我向大家保证过我们会有一条龙。而它就在那里。现在我们有了。它冲了出来。显然它一直在烧毁陵墓。查理·马特的尸体已经被带走，浸入了地狱。你还需要什么证据？好吧，这对我来说足够了。好吧，但并不是教堂里的每个人都认为查理是个坏人。
as if it had been burned. And that actually happened. Well, right at the beginning of this series and in the episode we did on Clevis, I promised people that we'd have a dragon. And there it is. And now we have. Comes rushing out. It's obviously been burning the tomb. Charles Martel's body has been taken, dunked in hell. What more proof do you need? Okay, well that's good enough for me. Okay, but not everybody in the church thinks Charles is a bad guy.
事实上，有些主教认为他太棒了。难道不是吗？嗯，有一个非常特殊的主教，那就是罗马主教，也就是教皇。所以来自罗马的教皇——我的意思是他在这场争端中没有具体的利益冲突，他一点也不介意查理·马特对高卢的主教们做了什么。事实上，他非常非常热衷于巴结查理·马特。因此，在739年，也就是查理去世前两年，名叫格里高利三世的教皇给他寄去了圣彼得的钥匙，以及圣彼得被罗马人处决前关在监狱里时束缚他的部分锁链。这是一个相当清晰的信号，
And in fact, there are bishops who think, oh he's brilliant. Aren't there? Well, there's one very particular bishop and that is the Bishop of Rome, the Pope. So the Pope from Rome, I mean he has no particular dog in the fight, he doesn't mind at all what Charles Martel is doing to the bishops in Gaul. And in fact he's very very keen to cosy up to Charles Martel. So in 739, which is two years before Charles dies, the Pope, who's called Gregory III, sends him the keys of St Peter and a portion of the chains that had bound St Peter when he was held in prison before being executed by the Romans. And this is a pretty clear signal
表明教皇有兴趣与查理及其家族达成交易。而这非常及时，因为所有人都知道查理在世的时日无多了。到739年，他已经相当老了。人们推测，查理的两个长子，一个叫卡洛曼（Carloman），一个叫丕平（Pepin），将继承他的地位。但他们显然不会以国王的身份继承，而是以宫相的身份。不仅在罗马，而且在整个法兰克王国，似乎都有一种感觉：这太荒谬了。墨洛温王朝的国王居然还留着长发，被推着四轮马车到处走，诸如此类的事情，这简直是疯了。当查理在741年去世时，这种情绪集中爆发了，果不其然，他作为宫相的职责被分给了他的儿子们。因此，长子卡洛曼成为了东方王国奥斯特拉西亚的宫相，而年幼的丕平则成为了纽斯特里亚的宫相，其首都现在设在巴黎。而让这一切显得更加荒谬、对人们来说滑稽透顶的是，此时王位上甚至连一个墨洛温王朝的国王都没有了。他们的墨洛温国王用完了。
that the papacy is interested in doing a deal with Charles and with his family. And this is quite timely because everyone knows that Charles isn't long for this life. By 739, he's pretty old. And the assumption is that Charles's two eldest sons, one of whom is called Carloman, one of whom is called Pepin, will succeed him. But they will do so obviously not as kings, but as mayors. I think there's a sense, not just in Rome, but also across most of the Frankish kingdom, that this is ridiculous. I mean, it's mad that you've still got a Merovingian king with his
他们的墨洛温国王用完了。他们没有了。所以卡洛曼和丕平最初很难确立他们的权威。他们又不是铁锤。因此，他们需要一些时间来巩固自己的权威。他们想，好吧，其实如果我们王位上能有一个墨洛温国王的话，对我们来说可能会更容易一些。于是他们四处寻找，找到了一个墨洛温人，他叫希尔佩里克（Chilperic）。不出所料。他们把他扶上王位，他成了希尔佩里克三世。但解决整个问题显而易见的办法是废黜他，
long hair and he's being wheeled out on his cart and that kind of thing. And this is focused when Charles dies in 741 and sure enough, his roles as mayor are divided up among his sons. So the elder one, Carloman, becomes the mayor of Australia, the Eastern Kingdom and the younger one, Pepin, becomes the mayor of Neustria with his capital now based in Paris. And what makes this even more ridiculous and seem ludicrous to people is that there isn't even at this point a Merovingian King on the throne. They've run out of Merovingians.
废除墨洛温君主制本身，让卡洛曼或丕平或者可能他们两个都成为国王。但这里有一个问题，那就是：你该怎么做呢？因为克洛维当初成为国王时（这就是为什么他宣称自己是奥古斯都，为什么他吹嘘自己的长发以及自己是某个奇异海怪的后代的原因）。如果你想成为国王，你需要一个合法性的源泉，因为你需要向你的人民证明，并且在你的内心、在你的灵魂中确信，上帝赞同你登上王位。所以你需要某种东西，或者也许是某个人来提供这种合法性。那个人究竟会是谁呢？我们在中场休息后揭晓。多么大的悬念啊。这个人是谁？
They've run out of Merovingians. They haven't got one. So Karlemin and Pepin, it's difficult for them initially to establish their authority. They're not the hammer. So it takes some time to affirm their authority. They think, well, actually, maybe it would be kind of easier for us if we did have a kind of Merovingian king on the throne. So they look around and they find a Merovingian and he's a guy called Chilperic. Inevitably. And they plonk him on the throne and he becomes Chilperic the third. But the obvious solution to this whole problem is for him to be deposed, for the
不要走开。本集由 Dyson On Track 赞助播出。Dyson On Track 耳机提供同类最佳的降噪功能和强化的音效范围，是欣赏音乐和播客的完美选择。开启主动降噪功能后，可享受长达 55 小时的聆听时间，专为舒适而设计的柔软超细纤维耳垫，以及多种颜色和饰面可供选择。
Merovingian monarchy itself to be abolished and for either Karleman or Pepin or perhaps both to become kings. But there is a problem, which is, you know, how do you do this? Because Clovis, when he'd become king, you know, this is why he'd proclaimed himself Augustus and why he'd boasted about, you know, his long hair and being descended from a weird sea monster. If you're going to be a king, you need a source of legitimacy because you need to demonstrate to your people and be confident in your own heart, in your own soul, that God approves of your elevation to the throne. So you need something or perhaps someone who can provide that legitimacy. Who on earth would that be? We'll find out after the break. What a cliffhanger. Who is this person?
Dyson On Track，重制版耳机。请在 DysonCanada.ca 购买。开启主动降噪功能后，性能可能会因环境条件和使用情况而异，配件另售。麦当劳为您带来持久的惊喜。送给负责遛狗的彼得，以及帮你铲雪梯的克莱尔。当你通过麦当劳餐厅购买价值 25 美元的礼品卡时，
Don't go away. This episode is brought to you by Dyson On Track. Dyson On Track headphones offer best-in-class noise cancellation and an enhanced sound range, making them perfect for enjoying music and podcasts. Get up to 55 hours of listening with active noise canceling enabled, soft microfiber cushions engineered for comfort, and a range of colors and finishes.
即可获得一张免费巨无霸或麦香鸡的优惠券。详情请参阅参与活动的麦当劳餐厅。节日季已经到来。准备好散发一些光彩了吗？这个季节，送上一份道出“我爱你”的礼物，来自 People's Jewelers。他们拥有让您所爱之人闪耀的各种款式，从经典的钻石和宝石到耀眼的金饰。这是向他们表达对您而言多么重要的完美方式。现在就在 People's 选购，寻找那件特别的礼物吧。
Dyson On Track, headphones remastered. Buy from DysonCanada.ca. With ANC on, performance may vary based on environmental conditions and usage,ories sold separately. McDonald's has the gift that keeps giving. To Peter, your dog sitter, and Claire, who shovels your stairs. And to you, when you spend $25 on McDonald's gift cards in restaurants,
让我们庆祝爱情、友谊以及这个节日带来的所有欢乐。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们以一个巨大的悬念结束了上一部分，这不仅是本播客历史上最大的悬念之一，我认为也是整个人类文明史上最大的悬念：究竟谁或什么才是能够将王权授予卡洛曼和丕平的权威之源？这两个人统治着法兰克王国的奥斯特拉西亚和纽斯特里亚。这是一个巨大的问题。一个巨大的问题。而我觉得你刚才令人失望地剧透了一点。你说我们的目光
get a coupon for a free Big Mac or McChicken. See details at participating McDonald's restaurants. The holidays are here. Ready to spread some sparkle? This season, give the gift that says, I love you, from People's Jewelers. They have styles to make your loved ones shine, from timeless diamonds and gemstones to stunning gold. It's the perfect way to show just how much they mean to you. Shop now at People's and find that special piece today.
将转向罗马。那么请告诉我们，这个人是谁？好吧，当然，罗马是教皇所在地，听过这集、听到了这个阶段的听众可能会注意到，我们其实并没有怎么提及教皇。我想多米尼克，许多人可能会觉得教皇是中世纪欧洲的关键人物，因此可能会觉得这有点奇怪。但在此时，教皇的权威和影响仅仅是他们在日后中世纪高地逐渐形成的势力的冰山一角。因此，罗马主教，也就是教皇——我的意思是，西方其他神职人员普遍承认他是资历最老的。他是资历最高的主教，但这基本上也就是极限了。所以如果教皇写信给国王，
Let's celebrate love, friendship, and all the joy this holiday brings. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We ended with one of the great cliffhangers, not merely in the history of this podcast, but I think in the history of probably of all human civilization, who or what is the possible source of authority that could bestow kingship on Karlaman and Pepin, these people who are ruling Australia and Neustria in the realm of the Franks? Massive questions. A massive question. And you gave a little spoiler I felt disappointingly. You said our eyes
他会得到他们的尊重，他们会听取他的意见，但他们不一定会服从他。他可以向他们提供建议，但他肯定不能向他们发号施令。部分原因在于他根本不会去想这样做。我的意思是，这根本不会划过他的脑海，觉得那是他的职责。但即使他这么做了，你知道，他也缺乏这样做的手段。正如我们所说，高卢的主教们非常独立。他们不觉得自己受制于罗马主教。所以法兰克人，我认为他们尊重教皇，但仅此而已。而且毫无疑问，高卢的主教们，这些出身显赫的参议员后代，他们对罗马没有任何文化自卑感。你知道，他们不需要他。他们是独立的人。他们有自己的圣人。他们有自己的传统。他们就是他们自己。事实是，正如法兰克人对罗马主教不是特别感兴趣一样，罗马主教其实也不是很对法兰克人感兴趣，因为在罗马，你仍然有一种古老的假设传承，即阿尔卑斯山以北的任何人都是彻头彻尾的野蛮人。我的意思是，法兰克人仍然被他们视为那种留着巨大八字胡、穿着紧身裤之类可怕的人。是的，好吧，说实话他们也不是完全错了。但这也是因为，说实话，在我们一直在描述的大部分时期里，教皇有很多事情要忙，所以他们有更紧迫的事情要担心，而不是巴黎或图卢兹等地可能发生的事情。原因在于，他们仍然是以君士坦丁堡为中心的罗马帝国的一部分。因此，西罗马帝国已经灭亡，但仍然存在一个东罗马帝国，通常被称为拜占庭帝国。早在公元六世纪，也就是
would be turning to Rome. So tell us who is this person? Well, of course, Rome is the home of the papacy and people who've listened, who've got this far in the series may have noticed we haven't really mentioned the papacy much. And I guess Dominic, lots of people may have the sense that the Pope is the key player in medieval Europe and therefore kind of find it a bit weird. But at this point, the authority and the influence of the papacy are just a shadow of what they will become kind of in due course over the course of the high middle ages. So the Bishop of Rome, the Pope, I mean, he is kind of widely acknowledged by other churchmen
弗蕾德贡德（Fredegund）和布伦希尔德（Brunhilde）出生的时候，伟大的查士丁尼皇帝（虽然他真的不算节目的朋友，但他的妻子提奥多拉绝对是节目的朋友）。是吗？好吧。提奥多拉绝对是节目的朋友。曾出演过《爱情岛》，事实上还是《爱情岛》的冠军。无论如何，查士丁尼曾派遣了一支庞大的入侵军队去收复罗马，这在一定程度上是成功的。
across the West as being the most senior. He's the most senior bishop, but that's about the limit of it. So if the Pope, you know, he writes to kings, you know, he'll get their respect, they'll hear him out, but they won't necessarily obey him. He can offer them advice, but he certainly can't kind of give them orders. And part of that is because he would never think of doing it. I mean, it wouldn't cross his mind that that's his role. But also, even if he did, you know, he lacks the means to do it. As we said, the bishops say in Gaul are very independent. They don't see themselves as being under the thumb of the Bishop of Rome. So the Franks, I think they respect him, the
罗马被重新并入拜占庭帝国。这让罗马人感到相当屈辱，因为他们曾经是最初的帝国首都，拜占庭人承认罗马是更古老的城市，但他们也表示，与君士坦丁堡相比，它只能算是一座较小的城市。因此，曾经这个伟大帝国统治者的罗马人，现在自己也成了臣民。罗马对君士坦丁堡的这种劣势，在查士丁尼军队收复罗马后被体制化了。因此，拜占庭总督不是设在罗马，而是设在拉韦纳（Ravenna），由其统治拜占庭意大利。说实话，巴伦·拉韦纳曾经做过一段时间的帝国首都。
Pope, but not much more than that. And definitely, you know, the bishops in Gaul, these kind of grand descendants of senators, they don't, they don't feel any sense of cultural cringe towards Rome. You know, they don't need him. They are their own men. They have their own saints. They have their own traditions. They are what they are. And the truth is that just as the Franks aren't particularly interested in the Bishop of Rome, the Bishop of Rome isn't really very interested in the Franks, because in Rome you still have this kind of inheritance of ancient assumptions that anyone north of the Alps is a complete barbarian. I mean, the Franks are, you know, they still
教皇，但也仅此而已。而且显然，你知道的，高卢的主教们，这些森严显赫的元老院后裔，他们对罗马没有任何文化自卑感。你知道的，他们不需要他。他们有主见。他们有自己的圣徒。他们有自己的传统。他们就是他们自己。事实是，正如法兰克人对罗马主教不是特别感兴趣一样，罗马主教其实也不是很关心法兰克人，因为在罗马，你仍然保留着一种古老的观念遗产，即阿尔卑斯山以北的任何人都是彻头彻尾的野蛮人。我的意思是，法兰克人，你知道的，他们仍然
see them as these kind of awful people with enormous moustaches and tight pants and stuff. Yeah, well, they're not entirely wrong to be fair. But it's also because, to be honest, for most of the period that we've been describing, the popes have a lot on their plate, so they have much more pressing things to worry about than, you know, what might be going on in Paris or Toulouse or whatever. And the reason for that is that they are still a part of the Roman Empire that is centered in Constantinople. So the Roman Empire in the West has fallen, but there is still an Eastern Roman Empire, the Byzantine Empire as it's often called. And back in the sixth century, so that's around the time that
把他们看作是那种留着大胡子、穿着紧身裤之类的可怕家伙。好吧，说实话，他们也不完全错。但这也是因为，说实话，在我们一直在描述的大部分时间里，教皇有很多事情要处理，所以比起巴黎、图卢兹或其他地方可能发生的事情，他们有更迫切的事情要担心。原因在于，他们仍然是那个以君士坦丁堡为中心的罗马帝国的一部分。因此，西罗马帝国已经灭亡，但仍然存在一个东罗马帝国，也就是人们常说的拜占庭帝国。早在公元六世纪，也就是差不多在
Fredegund and Brunhilde had been born, the great emperor Justinian, not really a friend of the show is he, but his wife Theodora is definitely a friend of the show. Is he? Okay. Theodora definitely a friend of the show. erstwhile star of Love Island, winner of Love Island in fact. Anyway, Justinian had sent a great invasion force to reconquer Rome and that had up to a degree been successful.
弗蕾德贡德和布伦希尔德出生的时候，伟大的皇帝查士丁尼——他可真算不上本节目的朋友，对吧？不过他的妻子狄奥多拉绝对是本节目的朋友。是吗？好吧。狄奥多拉绝对是本节目的朋友，曾是《爱情岛》的明星，事实上还是《爱情岛》的冠军。总之，查士丁尼曾派遣了一支庞大的入侵部队去光复罗马，在某种程度上这也算成功了。
Rome had been incorporated back into the Byzantine Empire. And this had been quite humiliating for the Romans because they had been the original imperial capital and the Byzantines acknowledged Rome as the older city, but they also said that compared to Constantinople, it counts as the lesser city. And so the people of Rome who were once the rulers of this great empire are now themselves kind of subjects. And the inferiority of Rome to Constantinople is institutionalized in the wake of its reconquest by Justinian's armies. So you have a Byzantine governor installed not in Rome, but in Ravenna to rule Byzantine Italy. Will Barron Revenna to be fair, had been an imperial capital for a while.
罗马被重新并入拜占庭帝国。这对罗马人来说相当屈辱，因为他们曾是最初的帝国首都，拜占庭人承认罗马是更古老的城市，但也表示，与君士坦丁堡相比，它只能算是一座小城。因此，曾经这个伟大帝国的统治者罗马人民，现在自己也成了某种臣民。在查士丁尼军队光复罗马之后，罗马相对于君士坦丁堡的这种劣势被体制化了。因此，拜占庭派驻的总督不是设在罗马，而是设在拉韦纳，用来统治拜占庭意大利。说实话，拉韦纳曾经也做过一段时期的帝国首都。
It had, but I mean, it's embarrassing. Rome is not just a provincial capital, it's not even a capital at all. The emperor kind of lavishes Byzantine titles on the Roman aristocracy, Byzantine fashions become all the rage, people speak Greek, there are Greek churches set up in Rome, and Rome becomes essentially a kind of ersatz version of Constantinople. And for the Bishop of Rome, again, there are kind of constant reminders of his inferior status. So every time he celebrates a mass, he prays for his absent master, the emperor in Constantinople. Every time he writes a letter, he's dating it by the regnal year again of the emperor
确实如此，但我的意思是，这真的很尴尬。罗马不仅仅是一个省会，甚至根本算不上首都。皇帝把拜占庭式的头衔大肆赐予罗马贵族，拜占庭的时尚风靡一时，人们说希腊语，罗马建立起了希腊教堂，罗马基本上成了君士坦丁堡的劣质替代品。而对于罗马主教来说，同样地，不断有人提醒他那低下的地位。因此，他每次做弥撒时，都在为他远在君士坦丁堡的缺席主人——皇帝祈祷。他每次写信时，也都要用君士坦丁堡皇帝的
in Constantinople. And meanwhile, as he sits there in Rome, whether he's kind of wandering through the Forum or going for a walk on the campus marshes, all around him you get in this very memorable phrase by Peter Brown, the great historian of late antiquity, he hears all around him the crash of falling masonry. So ancient Rome is literally falling to pieces around the Pope. But the Pope is not entirely devoid of assets, is he? He's got his spiritual assets. He's still a prestigious person. He's still the preeminent head of any church in the Christian world, right?
在位年份来标注日期。与此同时，当他坐在罗马时，无论是漫步于古罗马广场，还是去战神广场散步，在他周围，正如晚期古罗马大历史学家彼得·布朗（Peter Brown）那句令人难忘的话所说，他听到的到处都是砌体坍塌的轰鸣声。因此，古代罗马在教皇身边 literalmente（字面意义上）碎成了片。不过，教皇并非一无所有，对吧？他拥有精神资产。他依然是一个声望崇高的人。他依然是基督教世界任何教会的最高首脑，对吧？
He's got a palace that was given to the papacy by Constantine and he's the heir of Saint Peter. So he's not nothing, he's not nobody. Yeah, you're absolutely right. And I think of all those kind of, you know, those attributes, being the heir of Saint Peter perhaps is the most significant because Saint Peter, the apostle whom Christ himself had named as his rock, he has the keys of heaven. So he has the power supposedly to bind and loose souls everywhere. and the Pope claims to have inherited these powers. So there's a certain level of potency there and what also kind of raises the self-confidence of the papacy, the willingness of the papacy to see itself not merely as a servant of the
他拥有一座君士坦丁堡赠予教廷的宫殿，而且他是圣彼得的传人。所以他并非无名之辈，他不是个小人物。是的，你说得完全正确。我认为在所有这些属性中，作为圣彼得的传人也许是最重要的，因为圣彼得——那位被基督亲自命名为磐石的使徒——掌握着天堂的钥匙。因此，他据称拥有在各地捆绑和释放灵魂的力量。而教皇声称自己继承了这些力量。所以那里存在着一定程度的威力，而且还有一件事也提升了教廷的自信，即教廷不再仅仅把自己视为君士坦丁堡
Emperor in Constantinople but perhaps his peer, maybe even his rival, is the fact that Constantinople, like Gaul, has been coming under increasing attack from Ameyad forces. And in fact, in 717, so even as Ameyad forces are spilling across Spain in the west, in the east East a great invasion force is advancing on Constantinople and investing it and this is one of the models for Tolkien's portrayal of the siege of Minas Tirith in The Lord of the Rings. There's a two year siege. By the end of it, in 718, this siege is finally broken but it's been an unbelievably close-run thing. The Byzantines have had a terrible
皇帝的仆人，而是开始把自己视为他的同辈，甚至可能是他的对手。这一事实是：君士坦丁堡就像高卢一样，正面临着伍麦叶（Omaiyad）军队日益猛烈的攻击。事实上，在717年，正当伍麦叶军队在西方席卷西班牙时，在东方，一支庞大的入侵部队正向君士坦丁堡推进并对其进行围困。这是托尔金在《指环王》中描写米那斯提力斯之围的原型之一。这是一场长达两年的围城战。到了718年底，这场围城战终于被打破，但这过程惊险得令人难以置信。拜占庭人受到了极大的
fright. And so too in Rome has the Pope because the Emperor in Constantinople is supposed to be the Pope's kind of sword and shield. But of course, when the Imperial capital itself is under threat, you know, the Emperor and his advisors and his military heads, you know, they don't get a toss about Rome. It's a kind of obscure, you know, kind of unimportant frontier town. And the Pope is kind of painfully aware of this. And when in the wake of the siege of Constantinople and the survival of the Byzantine Empire, the emperors in Constantinople try and reassert their authority in Italy, their focus isn't the north, it's the south because there they're being menaced by Aemid forces who are moving up against Sicily and against southern Italy. So that's where Byzantine forces are concentrated and in fact
惊吓。罗马的教皇也是如此，因为君士坦丁堡的皇帝本应是教皇的某种剑与盾。但是，当帝国首都本身受到威胁时，你知道的，皇帝、他的顾问和他的军事首领们，根本不在乎罗马。它不过是一个偏远、无关紧要的边境小镇。教皇对此有着痛苦的认识。而且，在君士坦丁堡围城战之后以及拜占庭帝国的存续期间，君士坦丁堡的皇帝们试图重申他们在意大利的权威时，他们的重点不是北方，而是南方，因为在那里他们正受到向西西里和意大利南部推进的伍麦叶军队的威胁。所以那是拜占庭军队集中的地方，事实上
they're stripped from the northern reaches of Italy and that then leaves the north of Italy open and exposed. And in 751, absolute disaster for the Papacy because Italy is invaded by a people called the Lombards. And this is kind of almost like a flashback to the fifth century, the age of the barbarian invasions, because the Lombards, they're a Germanic people, they're kind of ferocious warriors. And for pretty much two centuries, they've been parked the northern limits of Italy waiting for their opportunity. And the fact that Byzantine troops have been stripped from the north of Italy to go and fight in the south gives them that opportunity and they come sweeping down on the north and Ravenna falls to them and when the news is brought to the Pope in Rome he's
他们从意大利北部撤走了兵力，这使得意大利北部敞开大门，毫无防备。751年，对于教廷来说是一场绝对的灾难，因为意大利遭到了一群被称为伦巴第人的民族的入侵。这几乎就像是对5世纪蛮族入侵时代的一次闪回，因为伦巴第人是一个日耳曼民族，他们是一群凶猛的战士。在漫长的近两个世纪里，他们一直驻扎在意大利的北部边缘，等待着他们的机会。而拜占庭军队从意大利北部撤走去南方作战的事实，正好给了他们这个机会，他们居高临下地席卷了北方，拉文纳落入他们手中。当这个消息传到罗马的教皇耳中时，他
thinking oh goodness you know we might be next and there is really very little prospect that the Emperor in distant Constantinople is going to hear the lamentations and appeals for help from the bishop of Rome. So he has to look around for an alternative saviour. Right. And is this where we get back to the Franks? Because surely, and one very obvious person is one of the sons of Charles Martel and in particular Pepin. We talked about Pepin in the first half. So Pepin is going to step forward as the sword and shield of the papacy, is he? This is certainly the hope of the pope. But before we look at why he might be willing to do this, we should just go back and see what's been happening in Francia while all these events have been happening in Italy. So Pepin, as we said,
心想：哦天哪，我们可能就是下一个了。而远在君士坦丁堡的皇帝能够听到罗马主教的悲叹和求救的可能性微乎其微。因此，他必须环顾四周，寻找另一个救世主。没错。这就是我们回到法兰克人的时候吗？因为毫无疑问，一个非常明显的人选就是查理·马特的儿子们之一，特别是丕平。我们在前半部分讨论过丕平。所以丕平将作为教廷的剑与盾挺身而出，是这样吗？这当然是教皇的希望。但在我们探讨他为什么愿意这样做之前，我们应该先回过头来看看，当意大利发生所有这些事件时，法兰克尼亚（Francia）发生了什么。所以丕平，正如我们所说，
is the younger brother of a guy called Carlomanman and Karleman has been ruling as the mayor of Australia, the Eastern region. Pepin is the mayor of Neustria, the kingdom abutting the channel. And as we said in the first half between them, they have installed a kind of Merovingian cipher, Chilprit III on the Frankish throne. And the brothers get on pretty well. They seem to have been fond of each other, kind of quite unusual in the annals of Frankish history. And Karleman is a very distinctive character in that he combines a high level of kind of murderous ruthlessness with a very, very austere level of piety. So his most notorious display of ruthlessness. People who listened to our first episode may have remembered that we talked about a great confederation of Germanic peoples called the Alemanni. And they amazingly
是一个叫卡洛曼（Carloman）的家伙的弟弟，卡洛曼一直作为奥斯特拉西亚（Austrasia，即东部地区）的宫相统治着。丕平是纽斯特利亚（Neustria，毗邻海峡的王国）的宫相。正如我们在前半部分所说，他们两人在法兰克王位上扶植了一个墨洛温王朝的傀儡——希尔佩里克三世（Chilperic III）。兄弟俩相处得相当融洽。他们似乎彼此喜爱，这在法兰克历史的编年史中相当罕见。而卡洛曼是一个非常独特的人物，他将高度的嗜血残酷性与极其朴素的虔诚结合在了一起。他最臭名昭著的残暴表现是：
are still on the scene. And Karlemann decides that the fact that they still have this identity is a threat to his own authority. And so he invites them to a kind of conference and assembly at a place called Canstad. and all the leading figures of the Alemanni come here, you know, very excited to hear what Karlemann has to say. And what Karlemann has to say is, you're all doomed. He gives a signal, his servants, his aides, his men step up, slit the throats of all the Alemanni noblemen and that is them wiped out. And the claim is that thousands of them are killed. So Timothy Reutte, the great historian of Frankish Germany, he wrote that Kansnat did for the Alemannic landholding
听过我们第一集的人可能还记得，我们曾讨论过一个名为阿勒曼尼人（Alemanni）的强大日耳曼民族联盟。令人惊奇的是，他们
class what Hastings did for the Anglo-Saxon landholding class, i.e. wipe them out completely. So that's got rid of the Alemanns from the scene. But the other project that Kahlemann has been pushing in the eastern regions of his empire is to sponsor a man from Devon, a guy called Winfrith, to convert all the pagan peoples who line the eastern borders of the Frankish Empire. And Winfrith is a remarkable man. He's, as far as I know, the only Anglo-Saxon missionary ever to have had a power station named after him. Power station in Germany or in England? It's in Dorset. Oh lovely. Winfrith power station. So he comes over to Germany and he's very very effective,
仍然在场。卡洛曼认为，他们仍然拥有这种身份认同是对他自身权威的威胁。于是他邀请他们到卡恩施塔特（Canstad）的一个地方参加会议和集会。阿勒曼尼人的所有主要人物都来到了这里，他们非常兴奋地想听听卡洛曼要说些什么。而卡洛曼要说的是：你们都死定了。他发出信号，他的仆人、助手和随从们走上前去，割断了所有阿勒曼尼贵族的喉咙，就这样把他们消灭了。据称有数千人被杀。因此，法兰克日耳曼的大历史学家蒂莫西·罗伊特（Timothy Reuter）写道，卡恩施塔特对阿勒曼尼土地所有者
you know with his I bring you the good news of Croist. He's got John Adams' voice, President John Adams. He's from Devon, he's like Rich Nixon. I think we agree that Nixon was from Somerset. Nixon. Right, right. I think we agreed that Nixon was from Somerset. And he does so well that he comes to be called Boniface, so good deeds, and he's hailed as the apostle to the Germans. And actually to this day, he's the patron saint of Europe. He has an amazing impact. He converts huge numbers of people. And Karleman thinks this is brilliant. He's got rid of the Alamans. He's converting all these pagans to Christianity, it's all looking good. But then weirdly, in 747, he goes to Rome
阶层的打击，正如黑斯廷斯战役对盎格鲁-撒克逊土地所有者阶层所做的那样，即彻底消灭了他们。这样就把阿勒曼尼人从历史舞台上清除了。但是卡洛曼在他的帝国东部地区一直在推动的另一个项目，是资助一个来自德文郡名叫温弗思（Winfrith）的人，去皈依所有居住在法兰克帝国东部边界的异教徒。温弗思是一个了不起的人。据我所知，他是唯一一个以其名字命名发电厂的盎格鲁-撒克逊传教士。德国的发电厂还是英格兰的？在多塞特郡。哦，太棒了。温弗思发电厂。所以他来到德国，非常非常高效，
and he prays before the Pope and he says, I don't want to be a king anymore, I want to become a monk. And the king shaves off his hair, you know, the emblem of power among the Franks gives him a tonsure, the tonsure of a monk and Karleman retires to the monastery of Monte Cassino. He's gone mad. He's had a breakdown. Or he's had a religious vision, Dominic. His party has won out against his worldly ambitions. And there is actually, there's one chronicler who suggests that he felt guilt about what he'd done to the Alamans. So he said he felt contrite and because of this,
你知道的，带着“我给你们带来了基督的好消息”。他有着约翰·亚当斯（John Adams）的声音，就像总统约翰·亚当斯。他来自德文郡，就像理查德·尼克松。我想我们都同意尼克松来自萨默塞特郡。尼克松。对，对。我想我们同意尼克松来自萨默塞特郡。他干得如此出色，以至于后来被称为博尼法斯（Boniface，意为“行善者”），并被尊为日耳曼人的使徒。事实上，直到今天，他依然是欧洲的主保圣人。他产生了惊人的影响。他使大量的人皈依。卡洛曼认为这太棒了。他除掉了阿勒曼尼人，他正在把所有这些异教徒转化为基督教徒，一切看起来都很好。但随后奇怪的是，在747年，他去了罗马
he abandoned his kingdom. But the truth is we don't know. Wow. We don't know. What a bizarre twist. Yeah, it is a bizarre twist. I mean, people I think felt at the time that it was bizarre. And obviously it's great for Pepin. It's absolutely brilliant for Pepin because he is now the sole master of Franke.
并在教皇面前祈祷，他说，我不想再当国王了，我想成为一名修士。国王剃掉了他的头发——法兰克人权力的象征——为他剃度，即修士的剃度，卡洛曼退隐到了卡西诺山修道院。他疯了。他精神崩溃了。或者他经历了一个宗教异象，多米尼克。他的信仰战胜了他的世俗野心。事实上，确实有一位编年史家暗示，他对自己对阿勒曼尼人做的事感到内疚。所以他说他感到悔恨，正因为如此，
He's got the lot. And he decides because of this, you know, enough is enough. It's mad that I am not the king. But of course, he wants the reassurance that God approves of this. And so he turns to the Pope who's a man called Zachary, he's of Greek descent. So you can see that kind of, you know, evidence for the biting influence of Constantinople in Rome. But this is a key moment because effectively, the Pope is about to turn his gaze from Constantinople northwards to the Kingdom of the Franks.
他放弃了自己的王国。但事实是，我们不知道。哇。我们不知道。多么离奇的转折。是的，这是一个离奇的转折。我认为当时的人们也觉得这很离奇。显然这对丕平来说太棒了。这对丕平来说绝对是绝妙的好消息，因为他现在是法兰克唯一的统治者了。
And Zachary gets his letter from Pepin and in it Pepin asks, is it right or not that the King of the Franks at this time has absolutely no power but nevertheless possesses the royal office? And Zachary replies, no, it is not right. And Pepin says, brilliant. So he's talking about the Merovingian bloke who's still hanging around. He's saying like, let's get rid of him. Give me the crown.
他拥有一切。正因为如此，他决定：够了。我不是国王这太疯狂了。当然，他希望得到上帝对此表示赞同的保证。于是他转向了教皇扎卡里（Zachary），他具有希腊血统。所以你可以看到君士坦丁堡对罗马产生拜占庭式影响的这种证据。但这是一个关键时刻，实际上，教皇即将把目光从君士坦丁堡转向北方的法兰克王国。
Enough of the Merovingians. Who cares about them? Yes. And effectively Pepin can now feel that God wants him to do what he wants to do, which is to make himself king. Yeah. So in 751, which is the same year that the Lombards invade Italy and capture Ravenna, Pepin finishes off the Merovingian dynasty. So as Einhard described in the opening of this episode,
扎卡里收到了丕平的信，丕平在信中问：此时此刻，法兰克国王手中毫无实权却依然拥有王位，这究竟合不合适？扎卡里回答说：不，这不合适。丕平说：太妙了。所以他说的是那个仍然在周围晃荡的墨洛温王朝的家伙。他的意思是：让我们除掉他。把王冠给我。
Chilperic is kind of dragged out of his estate, his hair is cut off, he is tonsured, he is sent off to a monastery and that's the end of him. That's the end of the Merovingians. The Lion of Clovis is extinct, unless of course you're Dan Brown, in which case you think it's continued into the present day, but I think it hasn't happened. So Pepin now faces the challenge of kind of setting himself aside as someone of royal status, someone who is kind of elevated above the common run that the Merovingians had never faced because the Merovingians could claim that they were descended from this kind of weird sea monster. They had their long hair, they had all this kind of stuff. Pepin
受够了墨洛温家族了。谁在乎他们？是的。实际上，丕平现在可以感觉到上帝希望他去做他想做的事，那就是让自己成为国王。是的。因此，在751年——也就是伦巴第人入侵意大利并攻占拉文纳的同一年——丕平彻底终结了墨洛温王朝。正如艾因哈德（Einhard）在本集开头所描述的那样，
doesn't have any of this. So what he does is he turns to the Bible and in the Bible he reads of people who had not been of royal stock being elevated to the throne. Like David. Saul and David being the classic examples. And the mark of their becoming kings is that they are anointed with holy oil. And so this is what Pepin has done to himself. He goes to Soissons in Neustria, northeast of Francia, and there the holy oil is put on his brow by a bishop and he feels it kind of impregnating his skin and he has been elevated to a kind of sacramental level.
希尔佩里克被从他的领地上拖出来，头发被剪掉，被剃度，被送到修道院，他的一生就此结束。墨洛温王朝到此结束。克洛维的血脉已经断绝，除非你是丹·布朗，那种情况下你可能会认为它一直延续到了今天，但我认为并没有发生。所以丕平现在面临着将自己确立为王室身份的挑战，一个超越了墨洛温家族从未面对过的普通人的崇高地位，因为墨洛温家族可以宣称他们是这个奇异海怪的后代。他们留着长发，他们拥有所有这些东西。丕平
And then three years later he goes one better and he gets the Pope himself to come to Frankia to repeat this ceremony. And by this point, Zachary is dead but there is a new Pope called Stephen the Second and he is more than ready to do as Pepin wants, basically to answer the Frankish king's bidding. And the reason for this is that the Lombards are still very much on the scene. So in the autumn of 754, he sets off from Rome northwards towards the Alps and he is the first pope ever to travel to Gaul, to travel beyond the Alps. And there's a very dramatic account of his journey. I mean, it really does read like something out of Lord of the Rings, some kind of fantasy
没有这些。所以他转向了《圣经》，他在《圣经》中读到过并非出自王室血统的人被提升到王位上的故事。比如大卫。扫罗和大卫就是最经典的例子。他们成为国王的标志是他们被圣油涂抹。这就是丕平对自己所做的事情。他前往位于法兰克尼亚东北部纽斯特利亚的苏瓦松（Soissons），在那里，圣油由一位主教涂在他的额头上，他感觉到它渗入了皮肤，自己被提升到了一种圣礼的层面。
novel. There's descriptions of him climbing the Alps amid gusts of snow, and he's following a kind of ancient Roman road that's been left all cracked and overgrown by centuries of disrepair and he travels through a great wilderness of kind of sickening mists and ice and finally he reaches the summit of the pass and this is the gateway of the kingdom of the Franks but below him, so below the road, there is this great frozen lake and beside it that's the ruins of a long abandoned pagan temple. And, you know, for Stephen the Second coming from Rome, this is, you know, he thinks, what am I doing? This is a terrible mistake. But then he continues down the road into the land of the Franks, and he very soon reaches an abbey that had been sacred to an entire legion of Christians
三年后，他更进一步，让教皇亲自来到法兰克尼亚重复这个仪式。此时，扎卡里已经去世，但迎来了一位新教皇，名叫斯蒂芬二世（Stephen the Second），他非常乐意按丕平的意愿行事，基本上是听从法兰克国王的差遣。原因在于伦巴第人依然活跃在舞台上。因此，在754年秋天，他从罗马出发向北朝阿尔卑斯山进发，他是历史上第一位前往高卢、前往阿尔卑斯山以北旅行的教皇。关于他的旅程有着非常戏剧性的描述。我的意思是，它读起来确实像《指环王》里的情节，某种奇幻
who had been martyred by the Romans back in the days of the Roman Empire. And his hosts tell the Pope that there is no people in the world who are more devoted to the cult of the martyrs, to the cult of the saints than the Franks. And the Pope is told, the bodies of the holy martyrs which the Romans had buried with fire and mutilated by the sword and torn apart by throwing them to wild beasts, these bodies they had found and enclosed in gold and precious stones. So it's actually pretty passive aggressive because what they're doing is saying, we don't really need you. We've got our own saints. We are kind of holier than the Romans and you know, you're the bishop of the Romans. So, you know, just remember.
小说。书中描述他在阵阵风雪中攀登阿尔卑斯山，他沿着一条古罗马道路前行，这条路因几个世纪的失修而变得裂痕斑斑、杂草丛生，他穿过一片由令人作呕的迷雾和冰雪组成的巨大荒野，最后他到达了山口的顶峰，这里是法兰克王国的门户，但在他下方，也就是道路下方，有一个巨大的冰冻湖泊，湖边是一座废弃已久的异教神庙的废墟。而且，对于从罗马来的斯蒂芬二世来说，他心想，我在干什么？这是一个可怕的错误。但随后他继续顺着路走入法兰克人的土地，他很快到达了一座修道院，这座修道院供奉着一整支基督教军团，
What does the Pope make of this? I don't think the Pope really notices what he's being told because I think he's so relieved that he's managed to get across the Alps. he hasn't fallen into ravine, he hasn't been attacked by the phantoms of pagan gods, that he's just glad to be among civilised Christian people. And so he continues on his way, it takes him six weeks, he gets to Paris and there he meets Pepin and he sees Pepin and he immediately kind of bursts into ostentatious floods of tears and he begs Pepin to come to the
这些基督徒在罗马帝国时期曾被罗马人殉道。他的东道主告诉教皇，世界上没有任何人比法兰克人更虔诚于殉道者崇拜和圣徒崇拜。教皇被告知，罗马人用火埋葬、用剑残害、并扔给野兽撕裂的圣殉道者的遗体，已经被他们找到并用黄金和宝石封存起来。这实际上相当具有被动攻击性，因为他们的做法是在说：我们其实不需要你。我们有自己的圣徒。我们比罗马人更神圣，你知道的，你是罗马人的主教。所以，请记住这一点。
protection of Saint Peter and then he goes with Pepin up to the great abbey of Saint Denis which is where Gilles Martel had been buried, obviously where the dragon had been hanging out and there in Saint Denis he anoints him a second time and just for good measure he salutes not just Pepin as the anointed king of God, but the Franks themselves as the new Israelites. He hails them as a chosen generation, a royal priesthood, a holy nation, a peculiar people. So essentially the Pope is now lending his prestige to the self-conceit of the Franks that they are something special. Will Do the Franks live up to their side of the bargain? Because obviously he's looking to them to protect him against the Lombards, isn't he?
教皇对此作何感想？我认为教皇并没有真正注意到他被告知的内容，因为我认为他为自己成功翻越阿尔卑斯山而感到如此宽慰，他没有掉进峡谷，也没有受到异教神明幻影的袭击，以至于他只是为自己身处文明的基督教人民之中而感到高兴。于是他继续他的旅程，花了六周时间，他到达了巴黎，在那里他遇到了丕平，他看到了丕平，并立即情绪激动地泪如雨下，他恳求丕平前来
Will He is. He absolutely lives up to his side of the bargain. So 755, one year after he's been anointed by the Pope, he crosses the Alps, he invades Lombardy, he smashes the Lombard king, gets the Lombard king to submit. Two years later the Lombards are causing trouble again so Pepin returns to northern Italy, inflicts an even more crushing defeat on the Lombards and this time all the territories that the Lombards had conquered from Byzantium are given by Pepin to the Pope or rather to Saint Peter but effectively to the Pope and Pepin then goes down to Rome and he has all the keys of the cities that he's conquered and he lays them on the tomb of Saint Peter, on the tomb of
保护圣彼得，然后他与丕平一起前往圣德尼大修道院（Abbey of Saint Denis）——查理·马特就是被埋葬在那里，显然也是那条巨龙曾经盘踞的地方——并在圣德尼，他第二次为丕平涂抹圣油，而且为了保险起见，他不仅向作为上帝受膏国王的丕平致敬，还将法兰克人本身尊为新的以色列人。他称他们为被拣选的族类、君尊的祭司、圣洁的国民、属神的子民。因此，本质上，教皇现在是将自己的声望借给了法兰克人那种自命不凡的优越感，让他们觉得自己是特殊的存在。法兰克人会兑现他们的诺言吗？因为很明显，他是指望他们来保护他免受伦巴第人的侵害，不是吗？
the Apostle and of course as Saint Peter's caretaker is the Pope so effectively the Pope is now the master of this great swathe of lands that previously had been ruled by the Emperor in Constantinople and then had been purloined by the Lombard King. And the news of this when it reaches Constantinople, I mean, the emperor is actually furious. He says these are mine, but the Pope, you know, he doesn't care. He shifted his loyalty. He's no longer team Constantinople. He's now very much team Frank. And the reason for that is that Pepin and the Franks have, you know, plucked him and the papacy from the absolute jaws of disaster. And God's hand is also evident in the greatness of Pepin in the wake of his anointing, because following Stephen's arrival in Paris and his hailing of the Franks as a holy people, everything goes absolutely brilliantly for them, absolutely amazingly. And in fact, by the time that Pepin dies in 768, he has set the Frankish monarchy and the Frankish empire
会的。他绝对兑现了他的诺言。因此，在755年——也就是他被教皇涂抹圣油的一年后——他越过阿尔卑斯山，入侵伦巴第，击溃了伦巴第国王，迫使伦巴第国王臣服。两年后，伦巴第人再次制造麻烦，于是丕平重返意大利北部，对伦巴第人进行了更具毁灭性的打击，这一次，伦巴第人从拜占庭征服的所有领土都被丕平赠予了教皇，或者更确切地说是赠予圣彼得，但实际上就是给了教皇。随后丕平来到罗马，他带着他所征服的城市的所有钥匙，把它们放在了圣彼得的墓上、使徒的墓上，
on even more solid and impressive foundations than Charles Martel has done. So the taming of the Lombards is only one of Pepin's triumphs. He also effectively clears the Arabs from the south of Frankia, kind of expels them beyond the Pyrenees. Aquitaine is also absolutely and definitively reduced to obedience. So I said that Odo, the great Duke of Aquitaine, who'd fought with Charles Martel at Tor, he's retired to a monastery but his son and his grandson had tried to continue the struggle, Pepin not having any of it. The last duke of Aquitaine, Odo's grandson, gets murdered by his own followers because they think he's such a loser and after that there's no more talk of an independent Aquitaine. The whole while Pepin has continued Charles Martel's devotion to military
当然，作为圣彼得的看管人，教皇实际上现在成了这片广袤土地的主人，这片土地以前由君士坦丁堡的皇帝统治，后来被伦巴第国王窃取。当这个消息传到君士坦丁堡时，皇帝实际上愤怒极了。他说这些是我的土地，但教皇对此根本不在乎。他已经转变了忠诚对象。他不再是君士坦丁堡阵营的人了。他现在坚定地站在法兰克阵营这边。原因在于丕平和法兰克人将他和教廷从绝对的灾难边缘拯救了出来。而上帝之手也在丕平受膏后所展现的伟大中显现出来，因为在斯蒂芬抵达巴黎并尊法兰克人为圣洁民族之后，一切对他们来说都变得绝对完美、绝对神奇。事实上，到768年丕平去世时，他为法兰克君主国和法兰克帝国
discipline, He's recruited more heavy cavalry, he's regooned his infantry so that they're an absolute peak of discipline and fitness and expertise. He continues to sponsor missionary work on the eastern flank of his empire among the pagan Germans and all of which means that when he dies he leaves to his two eldest sons, the elder one is called Charles, the younger one, confusingly, is called Carloman, absolute waves of Carlomans in this episode. But he leaves to them a kingdom that's not just the foremost power in Western Europe, but is obviously absolutely primed to become even more formidable. You know,
奠定的基础，比查理·马特所做的还要坚实和宏伟。因此，驯服伦巴第人只是丕平的功绩之一。他还实际上将阿拉伯人从法兰克尼亚南部清除出去，把他们驱逐到了比利牛斯山脉之外。阿基坦（Aquitaine）也绝对地、彻底地归顺了。正如我所说，曾在图尔与查理·马特并肩作战的阿基坦伟大公爵厄多（Odo）已经退隐到修道院，但他的儿子和孙子曾试图继续抗争，丕平可不吃这一套。阿基坦的最后一任公爵——厄多的孙子——被他自己的追随者谋杀了，因为他们觉得他是个十足的失败者，自那以后，再也没有人谈论阿基坦独立的事情了。在这整个过程中，丕平一直延续着查理·马特对军事
everything is ready for even more impressive conquests. But there's an obvious problem, this issue of two sons. So the Franks have a history of dividing up their realms, but to avoid fighting, to divide them up between different brothers. And when you've got two brothers here, Charles and Carloman, is there not an enormous latent potential for a civil war between the two of them? Right, so Pepin and the elder Carloman, they got on well. Carloman, the guy who goes off
纪律的执着，他招募了更多重骑兵，重组了步兵，使他们在纪律、体能和专业技能上达到了绝对的巅峰。他继续赞助其帝国东部边境异耳曼异教徒中的传教工作，所有这一切意味着，当他去世时，他留给他的两个长子——长子叫查理，次子令人困惑地叫卡洛曼，这一集里到处都是叫卡洛曼的人——一个王国，它不仅是西欧的第一大强权，而且显然已经完全准备好变得更加令人生畏。你知道的，
and becomes a monk. But the younger Carloman and his elder brother Charles, so the sons of Pepin, they don't like each other at all. And Pepin's lands have been divided up between the two of them. Charles gets this kind of half doughnut and Carloman gets the kind of lump in the middle. They really don't get on well at all and Einhard in his account he blames this on Carloman's advisors so he says that harmony between them was maintained but only with difficulty for many of Carloman's advisors did their best to foster divisions between the two brothers to the degree that some of them were actively maneuvering to precipitate an open conflict. But then in December 771, so that's only three years after the death of Pepin, a dramatic development.
一切都为更令人瞩目的征服做好了准备。但有一个显而易见的问题，那就是两个儿子的难题。法兰克人有瓜分领土的历史，为了避免内战，把领土在不同的兄弟之间瓜分。当你在这里有两个兄弟——查理和卡洛曼时，两人之间爆发内战的潜在可能性不是极其巨大吗？没错，所以丕平和年长的卡洛曼相处得很好。就是那个后来离开并成为修士的卡洛曼。但是年轻的卡洛曼和他的哥哥查理——也就是丕平的儿子们——他们一点也合不来。丕平的领地在他们两人之间被瓜分了。查理得到了这个半甜甜圈形状的领地，而卡洛曼得到了中间的那块。他们确实合不来，艾因哈德在他的记述中将此归咎于卡洛曼的顾问们，
Karleman dies of a nosebleed. Can you die of a nosebleed? I mean, well, clearly you can. I mean, was there foul play? Yeah. That doesn't seem to be in the sources any suspicion of that. And I think most historians accept that it wasn't a nosebleed. I mean, he seems to have died of natural causes. And that means, of course, that Charles is now really the only kid on the block.
他说他们之间的和谐得以维持，但只是勉强维持，因为卡洛曼的许多顾问竭尽全力在两兄弟之间挑拨离间，以至于其中一些人积极策划以挑起公开冲突。然而在771年12月——也就是丕平去世仅仅三年后——发生了戏剧性的事态发展。卡洛曼死于鼻出血。人会因为鼻出血而死吗？我的意思是，显然会的。这里面有什么阴谋吗？是的。消息来源中似乎没有任何这方面的怀疑。我认为大多数历史学家接受这不是普通的鼻出血。我的意思是，他似乎是自然死亡。这意味着，当然，查理现在真的是唯一的胜出了。
And he gets unanimously elected as king of all the lands of the Franks. And so he now has the reins of this vast empire that's been forged by his father and his grandfather. He alone holds the reins in his hands. And the question is, you know, as we said, what's he going to do with it? He's so primed, so ready to go on the offensive. And the question is, how far will he go? And I guess that there's a clue to the answer to that question in the name by which this new young King of the Franks,
他被一致推选为所有法兰克土地的国王。因此，他现在独自掌握着由他的父亲和祖父锻造的这个庞大帝国的缰绳。唯一的悬念是，正如我们所说，他将用它来做什么？他已经蓄势待发，准备好发动进攻，而问题在于，他会走多远？我想，这个年轻的法兰克新国王名字里就隐藏着这个问题的答案。
Charles, Charles is best known today because he is known by us, not as Charles, not as Charles, not as Charle, but as Charlemagne, Charles the Great. And in the next two episodes, we will be looking at how Charles earns that name. Wonderful. So if you remember the Restless History Club, you can hear the next episode and indeed the third episode in our Charlemagne trilogy right away. If you're not, you can hear them by signing up at therestishistory.com. What better Christmas present to yourself could there be? Literally can't think of any. But if you're Scrooge or The Grinch, then I'm afraid you're going to have to wait till next week, because we'll be back on Monday and then on Christmas Day with the final two episodes
查理，查理今天最广为人知的名字不是查理，不是查理，也不是夏尔，而是查理曼（Charlemagne），即查理大帝。在接下来的两集中，我们将探讨查理是如何赢得这个名字的。太棒了。因此，如果您记住“历史俱乐部”（The Rest is History Club），您可以立即收听下一集，以及我们查理曼三部曲的第三集。如果您还不是会员，可以通过在 therestishistory.com 注册来收听。还有什么比这更好的圣诞礼物送给自己呢？简直想不出任何别的。但如果你是吝啬鬼或格林奇，那么恐怕你得等到下周了，因为我们将在周一以及圣诞节当天回归，带来我们关于查理曼生平宏大系列的最后两集。
of our mighty series on the life of Charlemagne. Tom, a veritable tour de force. Thank you very much and goodbye. Bye bye. Are you a fan of The Rest is History but yet to dive into the weird and wonderful world of The Rest is History Club, or is there someone dear to you who won't stop banging on about the show? Well, here is a reminder that we at therestishistory.com offer gift memberships. So if you're good at dropping hints, or if you're short on a present for a family member, for a friend or for a partner, Tom and I would like to remind you of the ultimate Christmas
汤姆，这绝对是一场精彩绝伦的杰作。非常感谢，再见。再见。你是《历史之源》（The Rest is History）的粉丝，但还没深入探索奇妙的“历史俱乐部”世界吗？或者你身边有某个人对这个节目赞不绝口？好吧，这里提醒大家，我们在 therestishistory.com 提供礼品会员资格。所以，如果你擅长暗示，或者正在为家人、朋友或伴侣挑选礼物而发愁，汤姆和我想要提醒你终极的圣诞
stocking filler. And it is of course a subscription to the Rest is History Club, which is full to the brim with bonus episodes. It's got access to the much loved Discord chat community. It's got newsletters. It's got all kinds of goodies. Simply go to therestishistory.com and look for gifts. Hello everybody, Dominic Sandbrook here. And I'm Tom Holland and we have some incredibly exciting news to tell you, don't we Dominic?
袜子塞礼（stocking filler）。这当然就是“历史俱乐部”的订阅资格，里面充满了精彩的独家播客。它可以让你访问备受喜爱的 Discord 聊天社区。它有新闻通讯。它有各种各样的好东西。只需访问 therestishistory.com 并寻找礼品。大家好，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。我是汤姆·霍兰德，我们有一些令人难以置信的激动人心的消息要告诉大家，对吧，多米尼克？
We do. So we often say we've got exciting news, but this is genuinely very, very exciting news. We are thrilled to announce that after the sellout show that we did earlier this year, The Rest is History will be returning to the Royal Albert Hall on Sunday the 4th of May to perform live once again with an orchestra. And we will be bringing you a brand new show and this time discussing two more of history's most extraordinary, fascinating and iconic classical composers. In this case Tchaikovsky and Wagner. And these extraordinary lives will be brought to life thanks to the accompaniment of the renowned Philharmonia Orchestra conducted by the celebrated Oliver Zefferman. So that first show that we did this year was a truly glorious experience and we are hoping
是的。所以我们经常说我们有令人兴奋的消息，但这绝对是极其、极其令人兴奋的消息。我们非常高兴地宣布，继今年早些时候我们门票售罄的演出之后，《历史》将重返皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅，于5月4日星期日再次与管弦乐队一起现场演出。我们将为大家带来一场全新的演出，这一次将讨论历史上另外两位最非凡、迷人且标志性的古典作曲家。本案中是柴可夫斯基和瓦格纳。这些非凡的人生将在著名爱乐乐团（Philharmonia Orchestra）的伴奏下被生动呈现，乐团由著名指挥家奥利弗·泽费曼（Oliver Zefferman）指挥。所以我们今年做的第一场演出是一次真正光荣的经历，我们希望
that this too will be an unforgettable night. There'll be great music, we'll be telling great stories, we'll be delving into the history. So you had better get your hands on tickets for the show as soon as you can. And these tickets will be available from www.royalalberthall.com on Thursday the 19th of December with a pre-sale for The Rest Is History club members and Royal Albert Hall friends and patrons 24 hours earlier on Wednesday, the 18th of December at 10 a.m. That is the rest is history live with the Philharmonia Orchestra Tchaikovsky and Wagner. It's at the Royal Albert Hall on Sunday, the 4th of May.
这也将是一个难忘的夜晚。会有精彩的音乐，我们会讲述伟大的故事，我们会深入历史。所以你最好尽快拿到这场演出的门票。这些门票将于12月19日星期四在 www.royalalberthall.com 发售，“历史俱乐部”会员以及皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅的朋友和赞助人则可在24小时前的12月18日星期三上午10点提前预售。这就是与爱乐乐团合作的现场版《历史》，主题是柴可夫斯基和瓦格纳。时间是5月4日星期日，地点在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅。
Now the tickets are available for members on Wednesday, the 18th of December and for the general public on Thursday, the 19th of December and for the general public on Thursday the 19th of December and please make sure that you don't miss it. If the history buff in your life is always regaling you with the same old facts about Churchill or Napoleon, why not get him or her, and let's face it you, a present? After all, Christmas is just around the corner and a very happy coincidence, our first official Restes history book is now out as the perfect stocking sized paperback. It is packed to the brim with the most bizarre historical questions you never thought to
现在，会员门票将于12月18日星期三发售，普通公众门票将于12月19日星期四发售，普通公众门票将于12月19日星期四发售，请千万不要错过。如果你生活中的历史爱好者总是向你讲述关于丘吉尔或拿破仑的那些老生常谈的事实，为什么不给他或她——咱们面对现实吧，也就是你自己——买件礼物呢？毕竟，圣诞节就在转角处，而非常巧合的是，我们第一本官方《历史》图书现已出版，是完美的口袋尺寸平装书。里面塞满了你从未想过要问的最离奇的历史问题，比如
ask like what was the most disastrous party in history? Which British politician plotted to feed his lover to an alligator? And why was a Brazilian emperor mistaken for a banana? It's sure to make the festive period much more entertaining for all involved, and it is available in bookshops everywhere now. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
历史上最灾难性的派对是什么？哪个英国政治家策划把他的情妇喂给短吻鳄？为什么一个巴西皇帝会被误认为是一根香蕉？它一定会让所有参与者度过一个更有娱乐性的节日季，并且现在已经可以在各大书店买到了。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。